right so at a certain level if you if
you have this kind of
ceo mentality and i tell everyone i work
with you know don't don't wait for you
have license to lead
[Music]
dan rubinstein thank you for being on 20
minute leaders how are you
i'm doing great thank you for having me
here of course i have to say that i love
the brightness of your space
uh it's always very important for me to
also be in a bright space as i work
and it looks like you have a great setup
and i have to before we dive into all
the incredible stuff that you've done
whether it's uh running a company that
had over 120 patents
or being a an executive at a various
of the most well-known companies you're
a songwriter tell me about that yes
um it's something i fell into actually
when my son was five years old he had he
got interested in taking violin lessons
the reason he got interested in violin
lessons is actually also a funny story
he went to
we took him to a symphony concert and he
saw that the violinist was the one that
was
setting the you know tuning forever for
the entire orchestra right
the first violinist right and so he said
oh i want to study the violin
i love that he wants to leave yeah so we
signed it up for violin lessons
and um normally it was during the work
day so
my wife would take him in the afternoon
and one day she couldn't make it she was
she was also working at the time and so
i
i said sure i'd be happy to take him and
i went there with him
and i was so excited to to do something
like that with him i came home and said
i told my wife
i'm going to study violin together with
him
she looks at me she goes you're crazy
you play the guitar already why don't
you
why don't you do more with the car and
so i ended up looking for what
how can i expand my horizons with guitar
i ended up studying jazz guitar
and then as i was learning all these
chords and
melodies i started just setting poetry
to the music and
wow over time i just started writing
more and more songs and it's been fun
i've i've actually i'm about to publish
an album
in a few weeks my first album it's
called stolen moments
i have to say i'm surprised that i'm not
surprised it keeps them it keeps amazing
me how
the busiest people that i get to
interview are the ones that are doing
the most amazing things
and and the ones that are following
their passions and and i just love it i
have to say that i'm also drawing a very
big parallel to my to my own father
he's a fantastic mathematician and you
know
he's also in the high tech industry for
a long time but he's a jazz musician
and he plays with it with some with his
friends all the time and you me you you
make time for your passions
i just love it but dan you know
princeton masters and
masters at stanford phd in statistics at
stanford
you go on to be the president of the ceo
of reflectivity
right it's sold to texas instruments
with over 120 patents
and and so your whole journey then
moving on to
to google and facebook and palantir
talk to me a little bit about did you
plan ahead to do so many
incredible things on your journey was
there any
strategy in in planning this ahead
um you know the i'll tell you it's a
funny story
because i don't think you can predict 10
20 30 years out
everyone thinks they know what's what
they're going to be doing but it's very
hard to know where the world is going to
go
so when i was growing up my both my
parents were engineers
and i got very interested in engineering
uh and at the end of high school i
started we had you know we had an apple
ii clone that my dad had built from the
kit and
soldered himself and i started getting
interested in programming it and one of
the first
programs serious programs that i built
was actually a program to conjugate
hebrew verbs
wow so yeah it was a very nice program i
created shape tables for all the hebrew
alphabet and you know
you know the hebrew grammar is very
mathematical and
and orderly so you can actually create a
very clear algorithm for how to
conjugate different words based on their
on the letters in them
and when i was applying to universities
the guy who interviewed me
for princeton was actually an engineer
and a linguist and he got very
interested
in what i was doing and he said look if
you get into princeton send me a letter
and
you know if you know how to code i mean
i can hire you
he was working he was working at bell
northern research
in montreal um doing speech recognition
and so from there i got very interested
in automatic
this is automated speech recognition
today it's everyone takes it for granted
that you can pick up your phone and talk
to siri
but back then this was new
groundbreaking stuff uh
and i got very interested and very
passionate on how do you train computers
to recognize
human speech human handwriting all these
kinds of questions and that's
that's what led me to go to stanford and
get my phd in
in that field driven by curiosity that's
what i'm hearing here
very very cool and i have to be freaking
sorry
if you forget to because it has to go
side by side with this this curiosity
also leads you to then create a company
that is steered by curiosity right you
don't just
stumble upon creating 120 patents
selling to texas instruments so that's
actually funny because
when i was at stanford you know
finishing my phd in statistics
the thing that i thought i was going to
do and this is back in 1998
which is coincidentally the same time
that google was getting started
um i thought i was going to go and start
a data mining company i was
i was taking entrepreneurship classes at
stanford
learning you know including at the
business school thinking about
okay i want to start a company i'm very
interested about data
all these new you know the internet was
i mean
the web you know the websites uh
websites were coming up on the internet
so this was all very new and very
exciting
and so that's where i was headed and
then my roommate my grad school roommate
uh came up with a way of um
making a micro mirror display so this is
a tiny display on a chip
i actually have one here on my desk to
share with you i don't know if you can
see it
uh yes okay so that silver thing in the
middle there
is actually a 1024 by 768 high
resolution display
so on this on this little chip there's
almost a million
little mirrors that move they're electro
electrostatically actuated
each pixel corresponds to one of these
mirrors
you apply a voltage to an electrode
under the mirror and the mirror is uh
you know electrostatically
attracted and bends and so you can you
can control where light goes you shine a
bright light on it
right if the mirror is flat the light
bounces from that pixel and you don't
see it
and if you apply voltage the pixel bends
and the light reaches the projector and
then you do see it and then you get
color by spinning red green blue
light and so we started a company called
reflectivity to develop
these micro displays for business
projectors and large screen tvs
the classic dorm dorm story
yeah if anyone knew what they were doing
they would never start this company
because it was
the most difficult technically
challenging thing so
the patent it's not like we had 120
patents that we knew going into it that
oh we're going to invent all
that you just needed to you needed some
so much
new technology to make it work yeah we
had 120 problems
it resulted in 120 pounds so we had
so many innovative things that we did
there
you know we built our own etch system we
actually were talking to companies like
applied materials to license
our etch system so building this chip
required so much surrounding technology
that it just
you know necessity is the mother of
invention right you you have a problem
you have to invent a solution that's
that's where it came from i'm already
upset that we only have 20 minutes for
this interview and that's why
we i have to move forward because you go
from there you sell to texas instruments
you become a product management director
at google then facebook and then you
find yourself as an entrepreneur in
residence at coastal ventures one of the
most well-known
venture capital firms in silicon valley
primarily focused on on health care
right
and that's that i believe that's coast
laws and i he came to speak to one of my
classes
and he was talking about the future of
technology with health care
and it was mind-blowing i is what was
that about why become an entrepreneur in
residence
after being an executive in three in
three companies
so so what happened was while i was
at facebook my dad started getting
complaining of lower back pain and we
thought he had sciatica
he thought he had sciatica and this went
on for months
and it turned out he actually had stage
four lung cancer that had metastasized
to his bones
and it went you know it didn't get
diagnosed for a long time properly
and by the way just as a psa if you have
any relatives over 65 that don't have
a reason for their lower back pain they
didn't have a chronic back pain for many
years or they didn't have an acute
trigger
one of the things you should go look for
is you know could it be cancer
and anyways he wasn't a smoker so there
was no indication you know that
that he had he had no symptoms of lung
cancer per se
and this kind of set me in a journal
like why is it you know this is 2012
why are we in 2012 and something so
basic doesn't get diagnosed in time and
you know just the idea that you know
companies like amazon and google and
facebook
you know you go to amazon they know what
you want to buy before you do
right you you go to google you type a
few letters and google tells you the
whole sentence of what you're you're
searching why
why aren't they focusing on also
diagnosing cancer
yeah or you know why doesn't healthcare
better use technology
the way these companies have and at
least in the us there's
you know there's several reasons for
this i think the major one is that we
have this
uh approach to data privacy that is very
that causes siloed data right you know
companies like amazon and google and
facebook they aggregate the data across
all users and build very sophisticated
predictive models from that right
healthcare for the most part especially
in the u.s doesn't work that way right
data is protected it's siloed um
and the efforts i don't think there's
enough um
[Music]
being done to really leverage that data
technology right
so i got interested in healthcare uh and
trying and seeing if we can
bring this approach this philosophical
approach from the high-tech world to the
healthcare world
um and i didn't know anything like other
than being a patient from time to time
you know i didn't really
know much about health care so i thought
i would spend a couple years just trying
to immerse myself see
see what you know where i could learn
where i could help
um and so the first opportunity actually
was um you know i
i had known vanode for many years
because
i actually when we were fundraising for
reflectivity we actually pitched him
really i think he was yeah i think he
was still at kleiner perkins
at the time if i'm not mistaken again
i'm sorry finterra but i have to just
drive parallel because you're when i ask
you you know we're in
april of 2014 after you've had such a
fantastic career already that that the
vast majority of people in high tech can
only dream of right selling
selling your own company that is doing
deep technology then being a product
management director of two
of the of the or some of the most you
know well thought out companies
and then you're saying that you wanted
to spend a few years to immerse yourself
in new technologies
and feed that inner curiosity and that's
i think you know that that's the line
the most inspiration that i'm gaining
from from this whole journey it's
driven by curiosity to the stanford phd
to solving a problem that turns into 120
problems
two then immersing yourself in
healthcare because of a personal story
i'm sorry i just had to
put that in there please continue
yeah um so what i you know what i
really liked about vinod he had he has a
very strong
vision and perspective around how
healthcare should be done and it aligned
very much with the way
with the way i was thinking you know um
how essentially
how can we superpower clinicians and
doctors using technology in new
new and innovative ways um and so i was
lucky i
you know he he was very kind and he
i was able to um get a position as an
entrepreneur in residence there uh and
it really
allowed me to see new companies help out
you know
on due diligence and i was planning to
spend quite a while there and while i
was there
palin here reached out and recruited me
to come in for a senior
product role at their company um and
they had a healthcare practice as well
which was aligned with what i was
interested in so i thought sure let's go
do this
and then ultimately after you know after
about a year um
i kind of decided if i was gonna do the
kind of vision i had for my healthcare
startup was not gonna be easily done
there so i set out on my own and
joined forces with my colleague cameron
marlowe who was the former head of data
science at facebook and we started
uh fizzera together that's a that's
first a fantastic colleague to to bring
on board
fizzera it's a it's the the company that
you're currently running
uh tell me a little bit about it and and
what i particularly like to also
hear from you is what is it like being a
serial and a second time entrepreneur
with your own company that you're
founding
how is the process different from the
get-go not just in terms of
the experience the other and the
knowledge that you already have but also
in terms of the perception
and and and getting you know people to
buy into what you're doing which is
often
one of the most difficult things for for
a first-time entrepreneur
yeah look i think obviously anytime you
do something twice you get better at it
the second time
i think one of the mistakes a lot of
entrepreneurs make and
i certainly made this myself the first
time around
you waste a lot of time on things that
don't actually matter right
so and what i'm going to say is going to
sound obvious but
when you do a company there's going to
probably be one two or you know small
number of things that you need to do
exceptionally
well that are different that are new
that no one else is doing
and that's where you should be 95 of
your time should be focused on that
right and then there's all these other
things that you
that you need to do like the you know
the corporation who gets what shares
hiring employees the accounting the the
lease the real estate
and an entrepreneur unfortunately
especially when you're starting out you
don't have money so you can't hire
all these people so you end up doing a
lot of that yourself but the quicker
you can get out of that game faster now
the good news is you know if i just look
at the changes that happened in the
world between
when i started my first company in 1998
and the second company in 2015
right it's not that much time right but
the world has changed
dramatically and all the things you know
when
now you have we work you don't need to
go and figure out a long-term office you
just go and get a
desk out we work and you can get started
right away there's software to start up
your own company you don't need to
hire accountant you know there's all
these things that you can do so if
anything i think starting a company
these days has become much much easier
and you get the leverage from all these
all these services and cloud computing
that you didn't have before
100 100 so i have to ask you know we
just have a couple of minutes left
dan you do so many things you've got you
had so many experiences what was the
most fun you've had
like what do you enjoy being the ceo do
you enjoy being the pm
the entrepreneur in residence which part
of the puzzle
look i i think every
every job i've had i think there's been
something amazing and fun on it
and it in some ways they're they they're
very similar in some ways they're
different so
when i i went from being a ceo of my own
company to going to google
one of the things i realized very
quickly is actually at a certain level
of abstraction
it's all the same right when you're a
ceo of a company
you have employees you have to convince
your board you have competitors
you go to a company like google that the
entities you know they have different
labels and different names but it's
actually
the same kinds of things instead of
having to convince investors
you have to convince management to fund
a certain project you want to get an
engineer on your team it's just
it's almost the same as recruiting an
engineer to come join your company
right so at a certain level if you if
you have this kind of
ceo mentality and i tell everyone i work
with you know don't don't wait for you
have license to lead
right don't license to leave i like that
whatever you do in your company
whether you're in marketing or sales
whatever
whatever function you have you have
license to lead
you know take bring a ceo mindset to
your work
right so you're not just doing a narrow
thing think about how it impacts the
broader problem
and and i think you get a lot of
satisfaction when you when you feel like
i have ownership of
not just what i'm doing but everything
it just becomes very satisfying so when
you ask me what's been the most fun it's
all been
fun because i bring the same mindset to
everything i do
i love it i just love it and i and i you
know before we end this i have to thank
you for
for being a source of inspiration for
myself and many others within j
ventures the early stage fund we're both
involved with whether it's
the screening meetings that i that i
just love hearing
both your input and everybody else's but
also in the in the monthly meetings
uh tell me a little bit about about your
experience with with
j ventures and investing in general
because you're you're wearing both hats
right
you're you're both you know taking three
hats tech executive
entrepreneur and investor is there is it
just a big mishmash or
are you really differentiating into
different buckets of your life
again i think it's all it's all aligned
in in the
same pursuit right of trying to i mean
you know the concept of tikkun olam
which you know to
repair the wall to make the world better
so
in my personal life this is what i enjoy
this is how i want to spend my time
making finding problems and improving
things and making things better
now i can achieve that leverage through
other people as well
if i invest in someone and help them and
mentor them
it's it's just a way of in a sense
cloning myself and
so uh some and i enjoy i actually enjoy
helping the next generation of
entrepreneurs it's something that's very
meaningful
for me i love it i love it so so dan i i
already uh
i'm i'm warning you that in a few months
when i when i go on my own path as an
entrepreneur
i will uh reach out and and seek for for
some advice and for your health because
i
i just can only imagine that the amount
of
knowledge and experience you've
accumulated and i'm personally on
a very similar journey and you know with
already my friends that were thinking of
starting some things together we had
we're pretty much we have
one big rule which is we want to make a
really big positive impact and we want
to feel
satisfied that we're doing something
both with the deep technology but at the
same time really meaningful to a big
market
such as healthcare and what you've done
both at fizzera and
with coastal ventures and before we
leave
thank you again for being on the show
what are three words that you would use
to describe yourself
um so i know you gave me a heads up i
didn't you know
not enough of a heads up but i'm sorry
for that no no
um so it's ironic but i wrote this down
at the beginning of the interview so i'm
not
uh i'm not making this up wonderful
that's great
i'll show you the note it's like it's
curiosity
oh you can't see it curious helpful and
efficient
curious helpful and efficient
don todava thank you very very much and
i'll see you at the next j ventures
meeting
looking forward to it bye
you